compte tenu de la gravité la gravité du
du sujet de votre terre d'élection
chère madame la sénatrice où je me
rendrai vous le savez ça me dit et je
commence évidemment avec vous tous comme
vous l'avez fait par avoir une pensée
pour les victimes odieusement lâchement
assassinés à nice ces trois victimes
ces trois victimes qui hélas vous l'avez
dit font suite à d'autres trop
nombreuses trop nombreuses vous
m'interrogez légitimement sur la
politique que le gouvernement conduit
face à cet ennemi
pardonnez-moi de rectifier qui nous a
déclaré la guerre qui nous a déclaré la
guerre et je les dis et je le répète
devant vous cet ennemi qu'il faut
clairement identifiés
c'est la première condition pour gagner
une guerre et nous la gagnerons cet
ennemi il ya un an je les dis ce n'est
pas tout les étrangers vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous même reconnu dans votre
question
ce ne sont pas tous les musulmans ce
sont les tenants de l'islamisme radical
qui ont des connexions à l'étranger et
qui vous le savez hélas on des relais en
france y compris des citoyens de
nationalité française
ces personnes quelles qu'elles soient
nous devons les traquer j'entends les
questions depuis de nombreuses années
d'ailleurs pour cela il faut modifier la
loi voire davantage
je ne ferai pas l'injure au sénat ou au
parlement en général de dénombrer le
nombre de textes législatifs toute
majorité confondues qui sont intervenus
en la matière notre rôle notre rôle
madame la sénatrice c'est de veiller à
l'effectivité et à l'application des
lois etc
stands et je peux vous dire et je peux
vous dire que c'est ce que nous faisons
bien sûr madame le corpus législatif
mérite sûrement d'être adapté je pense
notamment nous en avons déjà parlé dans
cet hémicycle au support des réseaux
sociaux dont se servent les ennemis de
la république pour frapper la république
là vous avez tout à fait raison il faut
revoir la réglementation mais il faudra
là encore surtout l'appliquer renforcer
les moyens de suivi des réseaux sociaux
renforcer les moyens de renseignement ce
que nous avons très largement fait est
que nous allons continuer à faire et
d'ailleurs vous le savez bien avant bien
avant
l'odieux attentat de conflans sainte
honorine le président de la république
avait annoncé un projet de loi qui vous
le verrez sera très ambitieux pour
renforcer nos outils de lutte contre cet
ennemi mais les actes de ce secteur
regardez encore aujourd'hui nous avons
dissous une association nous en faisons
tous les mercredis nous allons les
débusquer parce que ce sont des lâches
ils se servent de fausses associations
vous le savez ils s'introduisent dans
des mosquées ou des imams radicaux
brèche non pas la religion mais la n 1
par 1 nous les traquerons madame
[Musique]